got my test results back today and they
are positive
Colton Underwood has tested positive for
corona virus it's been kicking my ass
just to put it very bluntly the former
bachelors said he's been practicing
social distancing but started to
experience symptoms a few days ago the
main thing is I can't even walk up a
flight of stairs without being out of
breath or for the bathroom without
having to sit down because I'm exhausted
the 28 year old emphasized that young
and healthy people like himself can get
infected and encourages all his fans to
take the virus seriously there's a lot
of information going out in the news in
the media right now about the corona
virus saying it's for elderly or young
people don't want to do this I want to
let you guys know I'm 28 I consider
myself pretty healthy I work out
regularly I eat healthy Colton is
isolating himself at his girlfriend
Cassie Randolph's parents house in
Huntington Beach California fortunate to
have them unfortunately that means that
we're all in this together at this point
he captioned the video with we got this
Colton adds he doesn't want to spread
fear or panic but instead wants to
remind people to stay home and do their
part take care of yourselves take care
of one another I'm doing okay as far as
Cassie and her family they are taking
precautionary measures we're all making
sure to take very good care of ourselves
and staying healthy trying to one stay
positive to take a lot of vitamins and I
don't know get a lot of sleep but
revealed her brother is also struggling
my brother has been having some like
chest pain so I don't know if that's
part of it Cassie also posted a list of
all the symptoms Colton has experienced
from a simple headache to body aches a
mild fever to shortness of breath she
writes he's been weak and tired the
whole time bachelor nation is showing an
outpouring of love and support for
Colton former Bachelorette Becca kufran
gave advice saying feel better
skip the stairs and stay on the couch
buddy Ashley I can Eddie who was just
hanging out with him last week commented
thank you for sharing and keep
is updated if you feel up to it hope you
get well quickly
[Music]